un avión de combate ucraniano sobrevuela
los campos agrícolas en el norte de la
región de dunniesk el frente ahora se
encuentra a 50 kilómetros de distancia
pero el verano anterior estaba a tan
solo 10 km de estos Campos que fueron
bombardeados constantemente todos
nuestros Campos miren 1 2 3 todos están
plagados de misiles y cohetes que
cayeron ahí ni siquiera sabemos qué
tipos de municiones son miren encontré
este pedazo de metralla sin siquiera ir
al campo este explotó Pero hay pedazos
que no han explotado todavía y pueden
estar en cualquier parte
son de bombas de racimo por allá en el
costado derecho encontramos un
contenedor lleno de Minas antipersona
en la granja donde trabaja Víctor huanes
no hubo cosecha el otoño pasado la única
actividad de la empresa durante estos
días es ayudar a otros granjeros a
limpiar la poca producción que pudieron
sacar una actividad que se acabará
pronto
todo está detenido la agricultura se
está desplomando los ingresos se están
desplomando las personas son cada vez
más pobres
No hay nada de desarrollo sin embargo
aquí las propiedades y sus maquinarias
están intactas los granjeros perderán un
año pero las explotaciones agrícolas
podrán sobrevivir en la región de gersón
devastada por la ocupación rusa las
perspectivas son más sombrías van a ver
muchas ruinas a lo largo de la carretera
no hay una sola casa intacta en este
pueblo y algunas están totalmente
destruidas
nos lleva a sus campos
parece que los muchachos encontraron
algo
[Aplausos]
Bueno vamos a ver
el tractor hizo la ronda entonces en
términos de seguridad está todo bien
sergi cómo lo viste Aunque al principio
solo quería marcar la ubicación
bolodimir cambia de opinión como solo le
falta el detonador simplemente lo vamos
a recoger con cuidado
el artefacto pesa 40 kilos
y sacarlo del campo
yo debería haber conducido el tractor no
ten cuidado
el campo fue inspeccionado pero no está
totalmente limpio bolodimir pone
listones blancos en los lugares donde
hay municiones que no han explotado y
que no pueden ser transportadas los
tractores las rodean
si no trabajamos las tierras en las
zonas donde creemos que hay menos
objetivos peligrosos
el 2023 será un año en blanco
la ciudad más cercana la alcaldesa se
preocupa bolodin Mire su amigo y no le
gusta saber que trabaja en los campos
cerca de dispositivos que pueden
explotar
miren es una persona perfectamente
razonable pero las circunstancias lo
obligan a actuar de esa manera
me enteré Solo hasta hoy y no estoy
contenta las tierras que cultivas son
alquiladas entienden y los propietarios
de preguntan cuando nos vas a pagar
Es como si viviéramos en mundos
diferentes
Bueno me voy
Dios mío
las personas que van a los campos sin
desminar mueren por las explosiones es
grave ahora incluso hay publicidades en
internet de empresas privadas de
desminado que lo harían por dinero
pero no hay dinero
las personas han perdido su material sus
granos las cosechas que habían
almacenado
todo lo que podían haber vendido para
ganar algo de dinero quedó destruido
tan solo en este pequeño Distrito el mes
pasado hubo tres accidentes que
involucraron obreros agrícolas y Minas
dos fueron mortales los dos conductores
de tractor que se ven en esta foto
sobrevivieron Pero es tan gravemente
heridos la carne de mi brazo quedó
desgarrada hasta el hueso
Aquí también
en la pierna el hueso está roto Entonces
no puede soportar peso
fue doloroso pero lo aguante
la operación salió bien
dicen que me voy a recuperar apenas
pueda ponerse de pie mi cola quiere
volver a trabajar soy el único hijo de
mi madre nuestra casa quedó destruida
entonces tengo que seguir arriesgándome
si quiero ahorrar y reconstruir la casa
o comprar otra
mi cola dice que su jefe le prometió que
su trabajo lo estaría esperando cuando
salga pero no con el mismo tractor
Este es su jefe está preparando la
temporada de siembra para la primavera
pero también pide ayuda para reconstruir
su granero
aquí era donde almacenábamos nuestras
cosechas
todo quedó destruido después de que
nuestro soldado liberaran la zona
considera que alrededor del 40% de sus
tierras podrían ser cultivadas en
primavera Espera que puedan ser más y
por eso Sigue inspeccionando los campos
por su cuenta con lo que tiene a mano
aquí hay esquirlas nos quiere Mostrar
algo que encontró antes esas son Minas
antitanque si uno pasa por encima de
ellas se acabó y miren está alineada
hasta el otro lado del campo en otro
campo ayma los cultivos que no se
cosecharon dice que además de fertilizar
los suelos eso ayudará a ver con más
facilidad los dispositivos artefactos y
municiones rusas que frenan el sector
agrícola ucraniano el pulmón económico
del país tanto en tiempos de paz como de
guerra